Is a potentially repeatable recursion
source like evolution witness a card
draw spell? How about something that
draws and discards like Matsilantly the
Great Door? Is that considered a draw
spell? What about so-called impulse draw
options like Leia the Blade Reforged? I
imagine you might have opinions on any
one of those questions. Maybe you said
yes to all. Maybe you said yes to none.
And maybe you're a diehard great door
fan. No more, no less. It would be
satisfying and lovely if I could just
flat out say exactly what does and does
not count as card draw among these. But
unfortunately, it's a bit more
complicated than that. Fundamentally,
the source of ambiguity here is that
card draw as a concept often gets
treated as one singular thing, but it's
actually more like a web of overlapping
solutions to achieve a handful of
different goals. And different decks
will want different sorts of things
deemed card draw for completely
different reasons. The goals of card
draw are a little fuzzy, but broadly
there are two main ones that decks will
be focused on. Spending excess mana and
finding particular cards. Let's start
with that first one. The word excess
actually might be a bit misleading
because for the sorts of decks that will
most want to think about their card draw
this way, getting excess mana is often a
large point of the deck. The most
obvious deck style that fits within this
description would be battle cruiser
mid-range, a type of deck that is
typically late game focused and involves
lots of ramp. My rata deck is an example
of this, and it's a good style of deck
to build for players newer to the
commander format because it follows a
simple principle. Spending more mana
than opponents will generally make it
easier to defeat them regardless of what
else is happening. In this framework,
this requires two simple steps. Obtain a
larger total pool of resources through
ramp. then figure out a way to spend
those resources in a way that is
supporting what your deck is trying to
do. This is actually pretty similar to
the process of learning a real-time
strategy game. Becoming an average skill
Starcraft player basically just requires
two things. Building up resource
generation and then being able to spend
all the resources you end up
accumulating. We can see parallels to
EDH Battle Cruiser decks with this. As
long as you're completing basic tasks
like hitting land drops, playing some
ramp spells, and spending all your mana
each turn, you'll probably be having an
okay time. And once you're at that
point, you can turn your attention to
the specifics of what your mana is
actually accomplishing. In the context
of this type of deck, a deck chiefly
concerned with managing mana gained
versus mana spent, all sorts of things
can loosely fit into the category of
draw. Adding X spells to a deck will
typically reduce its need for draw since
they're very effective at spending mana.
And the same goes for X abilities and
other abilities that are useful to sink
a lot of mana into over a turn cycle.
These aren't exactly draw, and you'd get
some weird looks if you tried to call
them that, but they absolutely perform
some of the same functions as draw in
decks mostly focused on spending mana.
The key here is going to be making sure
that mana is being spent in ways that
are actually effective at pushing toward
a deck's goals. Throwing a random
fireball in an Asheen deck might make it
better at spending mana, but an X-ost
damage spell probably isn't a type of
card that will generally progress the
goals of a creature-based mid-range
deck. The best available ways to spend
mana in a nasheen deck will typically be
creatures with onattack draw abilities
that synergize with the deck's
commander. And there are also a number
of utility lands on Mardu colors that
can soak up mana while accomplishing
useful tasks for a combat centered deck.
You might have scoffed at the idea that
a man-ync spell or ability could be
considered alongside draw. And for a lot
of decks, that's an entirely valid
impulse. Some decks want an ongoing flow
of actual factual cards they can play,
whether that be answers or utility
creatures or anything else. And that
brings me to a couple draw alternatives
that still lean in the direction of
spending mana. The first is cards that
exile cards and allow you to play them
for the next turn or two, with these
effects sometimes being called impulse
draw. These don't allow having cards
stick around until a potential future
point where they're useful. So, they're
best utilized in decks with few
situational cards and more general
purpose cards that the deck will rarely
feel bad about casting. Another popular
non-draw source of value generation is
recursion spells, cards that return
things from graveyard to hand. This
could be a big one-time option such as
seasons past, and it could also be a
recursion engine such as evolution
witness plus counter shenanigans,
scrapler plus some artifacts, or even
something discreet like Forexian
Reclamation. You could even include
graveyard abilities such as flashback or
escape in this category. All of these
options serve a similar task, allowing
already played cards to be reused again
in some way. These sorts of effects are
typically going to be strongest in decks
that involve lots of redundancy and
similar cards since returning a common
card type from graveyard to hand is
going to be pretty similar in effect to
drawing one of those cards. However,
these still tend to have limitations in
that they require having stuff in the
graveyard to function. For a deck with
lots of sacrifice or which is based
around instance and sorceries, key cards
will get into the graveyard all on their
own. But other types of decks might want
sources of self-mill or self-discard to
keep their graveyard stocked with juicy
options for returning. Generally, the
more self-mill or wheel style effects
you add to a deck, the more your
recursion spells will stray away from
the task of spending mana and start to
gain some genuine selection potential.
And this brings me to the second goal.
The second goal of so-called draw is
finding particular cards you need. And
this goal tends to be served by cards
that might be considered filtering.
cards that draw and discard or otherwise
filter through cards without obtaining
card advantage are going to be better
and better the more a deck cares about
specific cards. The most obvious case
isn't finding something like a combo
piece, but the same could go for a deck
that has five prominent centerpiece
synergy cards that would like to find
one or more of a more abstract level.
Filtering will have the greatest utility
in decks with a high degree of variation
between cards or variance between
different power levels. Seeing three
different variants of a lowcost beater
with a filtering spell like dig through
time isn't going to be getting a whole
lot of usage out of the card. While
seeing a bunch of wildly different cards
is much more potent. Likewise, if you're
casting Impulse, seeing four different
cards of roughly the same power level is
on some level getting less use out of
the card than if you saw three filler
cards and a powerful centerpiece. If we
want to stretch the definition of
filtering a little, and I certainly do,
tutors are the ultimate example of this.
cards that search a player's library for
a card that fits some set of
constraints. Solve the equation is
basically a Solundai vision that looks
at unlimited cards instead of six and
demonic tutor is basically an impulse
that looks at unlimited cards instead of
four sorcery speed though. So, it's
pretty balanced. So, do tutors count as
card draw? Do cards like impulse count
as draw? It depends on what your deck's
goals are with running these cards. In
some decks, it might be important to
distinguish between what cards give card
advantage as opposed to what cards only
give card selection. A spellinger deck
might run impulse, and it might be a
helpful card for smoothing out gameplay,
but if the deck is currently running a
fairly low number of draw engines, it's
not necessarily going to be a helpful
addition for purposes of maintaining
cards in hand. Likewise, if you have a
really impactful card you're tutoring
for, a tutor very well could feel like a
draw spell, particularly if it's a tutor
that generally searches up some sort of
value engine. A steel shaper gift that
exclusively finds a skull clamp followed
by sword of Frontier. That's a draw
spell. Get it out of that tutor
category. When I'm deck building on
Architect, I'll generally put tutors in
by draw category in two cases. if they
generally find a source of card
advantage or if the function of tutors
wholly lines up with the function of
drawing cards. For example, if I'm
playing a combo deck where the main
thing my draw spells accomplish is
digging for combo pieces or tutors, then
the purpose of my draw is almost
exclusively card selection and tutors
accomplish that. I've also reached the
same conclusion in the opposite
direction. My Brina deck is an aggro
deck with lots of redundancy, so tutors
aren't much better than basic card draw.
When I added IR's Oathworn because of
its synergy with the commander, there
was no reason for me not to group it
with the deck's draw because it's
performing the same task. However, in
other decks, tutors play a somewhat
distinct role. In my strongest deck, I
run tutors to find time civ because
that's what I need to win. But I also
run bite and defasa effects, which
generically draw cards when my creatures
hit players. This can help find time,
but it can also draw me into counter
spells to protect my combo. And if time
civ is up and running, but I don't have
a full combo, having an engine that
gives me an extra three to four cards a
turn is typically enough to turn a
couple extra turns into a win by helping
me find things to give extra artifacts.
Card selection and card advantage are
both helpful, and having a mixture of
selection only cards and generic card
draw that provides both works out to
fulfill the deck's needs in the draw
department. We can actually construct a
spectrum and place all the types of
cards I've mentioned today on it. On one
side, we have pure selection effects
that are all about seeing extra cards.
And on the other side, pure advantage
cards that turn mana into value without
seeing any cards at all. Ledger shredder
pure filtering. Tutors generally also
pure filtering, though a bit flexible
depending on what you plan to get. Cards
like dig through time still lean toward
filtering, though at least here you're
getting some actual factual card
advantage by being one card that finds
two cards. I'd also put greater good
here. a powerful green draw enchantment
that tends to churn through cards at a
fast rate. Nearing the center of the
spectrum, you've got things that
generate a decent bit of card advantage,
but that also do a bit of extra digging.
And this includes my personal favorite
draw X card in most decks, pull from
tomorrow. It's instant speed, reasonably
costed, and the disadvantage of
discarding a card is typically
negligible since it's attached to a card
that draws a bunch of cards first. You
could also put something like
Necropotent here since absent a
relicquary tower, you'll generally be
exiling some amount of what you draw,
even if there's a lot of volume of cards
entering your hand. Generic card draw
leans a bit toward advantage compared to
other options. Though, a lot of the
strongest draw is just generic card
draw. So, often times decks will focus
on this even if they care mostly about
card selection. After that, you've got
impulse draw and recursion engines. And
while the former is relatively
straightforward, the latter will vary a
bit depending on how well it's
supported. Recursion spells might lean
very close to advantage, though they
also might have some degree of selection
as well, depending on how much self-mill
and discard a deck has. It's often far
easier to get cards to the graveyard
than into hand. But the tools for hating
on graveyards are far stronger and far
more ubiquitous than cards that force
opponents to discard are. So, recursion
has some natural limits in how reliable
it can be. On the far end of things, we
have abilities that can soak up an
unlimited amount of mana. Kasig Wolfrun
is a land with a powerful activated
ability that a deck can sink as much
mana as it likes into. It will never
find you any cards, but it can grant the
value of giving a creature you control
plus X plus O and trample. And the only
cost to have this ability available is
running a colorless land. So, this is a
spectrum of what different styles of
draw and filtering will accomplish in
terms of value and card selection. But I
worry that all this categorization and
visual flourish and such like might
serve to abstract the issue beyond
what's helpful. So, how do you find the
best options for your deck? And how do
you know when you have enough? Let's
start with that first question. Broadly,
what types of value generation and
filtering you'll want will depend on
your game plan, your colors, and what
sorts of stuff your deck is made up of.
Generally, the more variation that
exists between your different cards, the
more you'll want to focus on filtering.
If you have lots of situational cards or
a handful of specific cards you want to
find, you'll want to lean toward cards
that allow you to see more of your deck.
Look for options closer to the right end
of the spectrum I gave earlier. Tutors,
draw and discard, top deck manipulating
cards, and so on. Notably, it's
generally pretty rare that a deck will
want exclusively card selection. So,
your task will be in figuring out what
amount and what forms of actual draw you
want to pair with your filtering. In
some cases, selection and advantage
options will mesh together quite nicely.
Recursion and abilities that can be used
from the graveyard work great as an
advantage source to pair with card
selection in the form of draw and
discard. The selection fees the
advantage options that might be a bit
mediocre on their own. Likewise, running
tutors to find a centerpiece draw engine
is another popular way to combine a
selection option with an advantage
option. For a third somewhat more
specific example, sometimes you'll have
creatures that do some sort of top deck
filtering thing on an attack or combat
damage trigger, and pairing these with
curiosity style effects can set you up
quite nicely for a second main phase. On
the opposite end of things, decks that
lean toward advantage as the preferred
card type typically include more
redundancy. Put simply, you don't need
to spend nearly as much effort finding a
specific sort of effect if you're
running 10 or 15 of it. I've also found
that needing less card selection tends
to correlate with a couple other things
as well. For one, decks that rely on and
leverage their commander more
aggressively tend to run less card
selection since they already have their
most important card available. Secondly,
decks that ramp more tend to run less
card selection and more actual factual
draw since they can generally afford to
sink more mana into multiple cards
rather than digging around for the ideal
one to cast. Neither of these things are
set in stone rules. You'll have decks
that want to find specific sporting
cards for their powerful commander, and
you'll also have decks with very
specific ideas of what they want to do
once they've ramped up to a lot of mana.
These are just trends to keep in mind
when you're trying to identify your
deck's needs. With that, let's talk
about the final question of this video.
How much advantage acquisition should
your deck run? If you're playing a deck
that doesn't care as much about
selection, focus on ability to generate
mana versus ability to spend mana. If
you're missing land drops, add lands. If
you're falling behind in gameplay
volume, add some ramp. If you're finding
yourself with excess mana, add some mana
syncs like draw, abilities, or graveyard
themes. If you're finding yourself with
a lot of cards in hand, try trimming a
bit of draw or orienting your deck
toward mana efficient but card
inefficient cards like single target
removal, lowcost ramp, and situational
parody breakers. You might think that
your first priority should be the game
plan of your deck, and that does matter
for sure. But for just about every type
of effect you could want to lean toward,
there will be versions that are more
mana efficient and versions that are
more card efficient. So you can always
be keeping an eye on that balance. Now,
let's say you care more about card
selection. For starters, you'll want to
be able to make sure that whatever
you're running card selection for is
being attained. Are you able to filter
into key cards? Are you able to find
your situational answers in reasonable
lengths of time? Once this seems to be
in a decent spot, start keeping an eye
on how often you're able to find your
actual factual draw. Typically, actual
draw will be at a minimum helpful for
finding interaction for what opponents
are doing, particularly if you're
focused on mana efficient but card
inefficient options. It also might be
key for getting more definitively ahead
once you have some amount of setup
complete, but don't quite have control
over the game yet. As you've probably
noticed, the point of this video hasn't
been so much to tell you what is or
isn't draw, but rather to give you a
framework to work with in analyzing
cards and deciding if they're what your
deck needs. A lot of times building
commander decks is reduced to following
a template. And if a template calls for
x number of draw spells, you're going to
want to know what counts as draw. And
don't get me wrong, that sort of
approach is a perfectly fine way to toss
together a deck quickly. And hopefully
this video was helpful in figuring out
what you would consider draw for those
purposes. But take a bit of extra time
to figure out how all the individual
working parts of your deck fit together
and you'll have a much stronger end
product. Thanks for watching and thanks
to Architect for supporting the channel.
You can find my decks and their lovely
draw suites at a link down in the
description. I'd also like to thank my
patrons for their support, some of whom
are on screen now. If you want to
support this channel, you can sign up at
my Patreon at the link down in the
description.